[Musique]
c'est moi un moment ça va
le boulot sa fin tout fébrile oui il est
blanc comme un mime
non ça va ça va c'est bientôt les césar
ah oui autres séminaires mais césar as
tu vas jouer jules césar à ses cheveux
tous nos maux qui passe ces mecs m'ont
kaduna césar il était vegan j'ai entendu
ça nous donne à bah oui je me cultive
fernand les césar c'est un petit peu la
kermesse des gens du cinéma
il récompense les meilleurs projets de
l'année ils font des discours et après
ils vont manger la raclette au fouquet's
moment on mange au fouquet's il sera là
gilles de route au m'attendais je crois
que pierre a perdu cet été
pour pierre il s'appelle plus bâtisse
sim est changée parce que tu adores
pierre niney et joue bien lui viola de
garmisch
ah oui oui justement je voulais vous
dire que moi je me bats pour ça
irrespectueux
jeudi j'ai regardé je trouve que nous
pourrions t'adore ce pack de tout le
monde
exactement ce sont des mal élevés des
sauvageons non c'est de l'auto dérision
moment c'est les gens qui sont dans la
salle qui te payent leur faut être poli
oui oui tu veux remettre un prix alors
justement tu vas pas montré tant qu
homme et non maman parce que c'est ainsi
tu montres et boutons que les cages de
chez le coiffeur
en plus des remarques il travaillait au
castel attendez il ya bien qu'il ya
quelque chose
oui les rigolos redire et toi tes débuts
aux jeux tu remets appris à faire un
discours pour remercier les gens qui
t'ont monnaie sa chance 1
c'est quand même un miracle je rappelle
que le conseiller d'orientation au
troisième avait dirigé vers la peinture
avec la tête qui là aussi quand je pense
qu'à 33 ans tu faisais encore pipi au
lit
ben amor ben on attend la kangoo j'ai
toujours une bouteille vide être à la
christine trotz rome
christie's coptes crop fatwa viendra pas
sinon il ya il ya une bonne ambiance au
travail parce que j'aimerais jouer a par
exemple l'amérique quand j'ai reçu ma
médaille du travail
ben les autres qui faisait la tête non
mais t'inquiète pas tonton on est une
famille
c'est la grande famille du cinéma non ta
famille c'est nous à moi je joue pas
brad pitt et ta mère c'est pas julia
roberts
non ça c'est ça que tu en perds c'est
pas vrai et qui c'est qui m'a présenté
des têtards cette année eh ben c'est moi
44e cérémonie des césars présentée par
kad merad
vendredi 22 février en clair en direct
et en exclusivité sur canal+
et puis je vais à los angeles pour les
oscars aussi